democrats and the liberal media are
lashing out at the gop over the
questioning of supreme court nominee
judge katanji brown jackson who's
nominated for justice with networks
accusing republican senators of racism
sexism and peddling q and on conspiracy
theories for pressing her on her record
here they go
josh hawley you know fist in the air
josh and slaveholder descendant tom
cotton reprised their q and on baiting
smears against judge katanji brown
jackson they were treating her like a
black shopper being that they were
following through the store a day of
grandstanding and speech making and
hissy fitting in the senate today no
republican has been more hot and
bothered than lindsey graham of south
carolina this is about midterm elections
appealing to cultural wars appealing to
a segment of the gop that
is into conspiracy theories in
particular senator blackburn's line of
questioning did you see racism in any of
that
emily msnbc's joyless reed never to be
outdone with the insanity uh yeah that
was that's absolutely aberrant i have no
idea why that was allowed to remain on
the airwaves and the hypocrisy is
absolutely mind-boggling not only with
that coming out of her mouth um versus
the the vilification that occurs when
people dare to critique or assess
someone's history of jurisprudence but
also that we see it amplified in the
media it's the continued collusion
between the media the white house and
these progressive left which is
essentially if you dare to criticize
someone's background then all of a
sudden you are insert racist
misogynistic a member of q anon etc and
then that same phrasing is parroted by
the white house and the mainstream media
that's what we've been seeing throughout
the hearing and it's so unfortunate that
the greatest losers here are the
american people the american voters who
actually deserve to be impressed by and
fulfilled by whatever future justice
sits on that court and instead they've
been treated to a circus and to
disgusting comments like that yeah
totally disgusting and then on another
note you have senator marsha blackburn
she had the viral moment of the week
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context
i am not a biologist i spoke with a
biologist this morning to confirm i am
still a woman but this is a judge that
was nominated and not easy it's actually
questionable if you actually knew me in
person ask these
you know this judge was nominated on the
basis of her sex i mean let's be honest
biden nominated her because she was a
woman so why not capitalize on that and
actually take a stance for women as a
woman i'm offended that she doesn't know
who i am i mean and who she is and who
all women are and what an amazing
historical accomplishment this is for
not only a black woman but a woman to be
nominated to the supreme court she for
for my intents and purposes has insulted
all of women across the country
yeah totally and meanwhile president
biden he knew what a woman was back on
campaign 2020 watch
we talked about the supreme court i'm
looking forward to making sure there's a
black woman on the supreme court i
committed that if i'm elected president
have an opportunity to appoint someone
to the courts we'll be i'll appoint the
first black woman to the court i will in
fact appoint a pick a woman to be vice
president
yeah
so carly he knew what a woman was at one
point i would think yeah i also think
it's ironic that the role of womanhood
has played such a defining role in both
justice kavanaugh and now judge uh
jackson's confirmation hearings because
back in 2018 we all had to believe
christine blasey ford because she was a
woman and we were in that time period
where we needed to believe all women and
fast forward four years and judge
jackson doesn't want to define the term
because you know it could pitch in whole
her whole pigeon hole her into
transgender issues and upset
progressives so it's just a very
interesting political
turn of events it is you mentioned the
kavanaugh hearing well the washington
post get this the editorial board i had
to double check that the editorial board
had this to say rob republicans boast
they have not pulled a kavanaugh in fact
they've treated jackson worse remember
kavanaugh was accused of serial gang
rape by a convicted felon now twice uh
that would be michael avenatti
you know it must be nice to write for
the post and just wake up every day as
if it was the first day on earth and so
nothing else that happened before
matters right um so this is you know it
the idea that she's been treated worse
than kavanaugh is completely ridiculous
i'm gonna say one thing the left wants
to wants you to believe two things when
it comes to this confirmation hearing
number one that katanji brown jackson um
is extremely qualified and competent to
even question any of these um the the
history of what she has done is out and
out racist but also they want you to
believe that she has gotten to this
point but she is so weak that she's
gonna fold under the basis of tough
questioning let's just
think about this um this woman is going
to the highest court of the land this is
a lifetime appointment and what i would
have to say to the left and anybody that
is saying this stuff is that you know
african-americans black women etc are as
strong and willing and ready to stand up
to intense grilling as anyone else so
stop making us victims it is tired it's
disrespectful to us and it's
disrespectful to her especially when
they're not asking about anything
personal they're just asking about her
jurisprudence fair questioning hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now